remember remember the 5th of november
happy thursday reject nation thank you
so much for being here they announced
that they would reveal this trailer last
week
and it is here today mortal kombat 11
ultimate official molina gameplay
trailer can't wait to see the queen in
action
katana they're
this is not how sisters behave
i really hope we explore the backstory
as this
oh
i love this environment too
i love those size gosh
[Music]
dang i wonder if that's hard to control
who needs ribs
here we go here we go
that wasn't finishing her no there's
more
gotta get the side going oh my god
delivered delivered
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
she won
that was awesome
oh man that was a delight that was
incredible
oh i don't think that's how sisters
should behave people
that's not how you hack out your
problems with jabbing away nope
it's not healthy no it's not healthy to
do that how many
stabs did she do in that trailer more
than you could get away with in an
r-rated motion picture that's for sure
that's my that's like my new favorite
kind of stabbing that i
see in action movies they're like
they're super just like really
economical
when they go to the rib that yeah i'm
not promoting
real violence everything you saw in this
video is pixels
i'm talking to youtube this is fake
youtube it's all fake
it's fantasy it's not real
the mortal kombat tournament does not
take place all right it's not a real
thing
oh man that was really epic i loved her
finishing move
a lot that's gotta be one of the most
brutal ones i've ever seen i'll
i mean i always love the the actual
fatalities because you know when she was
doing the finishing move yeah
you had that i got it i got lost in the
thing that was the fantastic
yeah yeah i do gotta give it to them
because
i've seen so many same things i was like
this is kind of fatality level
crazy yeah but they always have to
one-up that with the fatality yeah i
mean kudos to them because that was
disgusting but yeah i like the different
variations of the costumes molina
is that uh interesting player where she
could take a bite out of your neck in
the like how you see here but
they still managed to make her look sexy
well you ma'am that's part of her appeal
is that is that dangerous side she's in
mortal kombat annihilation right
yeah yeah that's right she fights sonja
blade
oh oh okay okay okay i recognize her now
it's an old costume i recognize yeah
they've covered up a lot since
the 80s and 90s yeah they toned her down
a little bit or a lot now she's more
about the game now she's more about the
fight you know she's more about the
the focusing on that you know she
doesn't have time for people to be
oogling anymore i mean she's still
she's got a family to bring together
pretty sexy she's still pretty
pretty yes all right guys well mortal
kombat 11
ultimate gameplay trailer complete so
glad this
is here guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe
click that notification bell likes
whatevers
we'll see you guys soon